um you look so different like and all
the things you do like this Hunger Games
Vikings like everything you do you look
so different that's so cool you're a
chameleon oh thank you so much I mean
especially for this like we're showing
an arc between you know when he's a
young man - you know I've been till he's
40 or something yeah with three or four
kids so so it's yeah I wanted to I
always like to switch it up if I can and
I actually I had a gift for you I was
gonna bring like this great necklace in
a box of chocolates but I think you also
like Nashville too because you're really
seeing a country song right you know I
really appreciate you sending this song
and I love it I love that you sound
country like I think if you like a lot
of country music now is starting to do
part from what actual country music
sounds I love traditional country music
you know I grew up listening it to the
likes of George Strait yeah you know
everyone from that era and randomly I
was I had some time off of Vikings and I
got on a plane and I was like I'm gonna
go to Nashville I'm gonna try to figure
it out and I had no plan whatsoever and
while I was getting on the plane this
like all these guys in like black like
attire come up to me and I was like
these guys got to be a band and he goes
hey man I'm a huge fan of lone survivor
which was a film I did a while ago and
he's like what are you doing in
Nashville and I was like well I'm trying
to figure out how to do this country
thing I want to I want to learn what it
takes to write a great song and you know
start from the ground up and turns out
they've played with you before it's
telly Kennedy and Curt Allison who
played with Jason Aldean great man yeah
so they've been producing me and and
yeah I want to release it I just wanna
look back in my life when I'm 80 and and
and it sounds awesome
thank you yeah like that's what went on
at first I was like oh it seeks country
and I was like awesome and it wasn't
gonna hear Canadian can even is actually
love yeah it's like crazy up there they
love it yeah I love it
I mean like the hockey dressing rooms
that's what we'd all be listening to you
know back back then so that's intent I
like country music cuz there's a story
yeah yeah they tell you they're I'm
gonna drive down to the gas station no
but congrats on Vikings character
because I had seen but I had no idea was
based off a real character like a
real-life person yeah I didn't know that
björn ironside was a was a real live
Viking and it was the first king of
Sweden and he said that he was the son
of Ragnar lothbrok who is kind of a
mythological hero we don't actually know
if he existed but I'm such a history
buff I love I love I love that kinda
stuff so yeah and by the way I just
watched your Netflix special you're
amazing
[Applause]
no I'm so good it was so wait do you
think that you would actually make a
good Viking after having to like cuz
it's been kind of grueling I read how
y'all like shot this and like how you
regular [ __ ] it's like crazy hard no it
really was one of the most trying
experience of my life
no I would make a terrible Viking I mean
it's not for divas that's for sure but
it was I mean it was a great it was a
great experience and you know and I mean
I have a story I mean this is this is
like they put a ton of makeup on you
trying to break you down and there's
like there's times where like just
because it's so quick and demanding that
you don't don't have time to put on
makeup and I'll never forget this one
time I I went down was like screw it I'm
gonna do it myself and I just pull out
this big glob of dirt and I stuck it all
over my face
and I realized after he was
[Applause]
that has been my life for six years that
was a great story
like did you wanna know I didn't have
time to take it off so I just give you
your very method I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this